harren security is something that a lot
of men feel and almost none talk about
30% of men suffer from hair loss by the
age of 30 that's a lot of guys the
people I hang out nobody talks about
hair they're uncomfortable with the idea
of balding because they expect that I'm
uncomfortable with it they feel like
there's no options at all they're like
whatever it happens I'm gonna go bald
look at my dad it was just weighing on
my self-confidence you think that we
need to get down to the root of this
problem
I noticed hair loss for me uh about when
I was 27 my wife told me I have a bald
spot in the back wait and when did she
tell you about she told me this last
night I think the first time is really a
dressed like this is something that is
real I was coming to this video at
self-analysis don't be scared to take a
look at it I ignored it for a long time
so I showed you photos of me in college
you're like oh yeah I could see it
started there I'm like what earlier you
discover it the better chance you have
I'm preventing it what's your perception
of hair loss and why it happens they say
might happen from the mother's father
side false genetics on both sides so
you're literally rolling the dice so do
your proper research look at your
parents look at your grandparents have
you ever done research I don't think
that I mean yeah it's because of that
inevitability and nothing that I do is
going to stop it men suffer from
something called androgenetic alopecia
men usually bald on top of their crown
area in the frontal lobe to the back
it's kind of like that Friar Tuck look
when what you told me is that it's
testosterone that's blocking yes I was
like so I'm too much of a man that's the
problem there we go it's DHT that causes
it which is a type of hormonal
testosterone it's hair miniaturization
that basically closes the follicle I've
just kind of given up we're here today
to discover what we can do for you I
love that self-analysis will lead into
hair scription we have a mutual friend
and you do his hair and his hair is
fantastic and I'm like I want that I'm
just like I'm going to corner you and
I'm going to get your secret as far as
hair scriptures concerning a thing like
how easy it is I'm applying a cream to
my head twice a day and then I have a
pill that supports strong hair growth
something that adds two minutes to my
morning routine my hairline wasn't
magically reappearing but it was slowing
down the process a huge Avenue that
people like to explore besides surgery
is a laser comb
laser comb right the density of their
hair is a lot more than at what we
started with propecia I tried it it was
fine in the beginning but I noticed my
sex drive and my energy were lower than
normal and you were really great at
making sure I understood how and why to
style my hair in a certain way there's
an old myth of let's just keep growing
your hair out and Emily will cover the
areas of concern I like sort of like try
to press it into place as much as
possible so it's you don't see the spots
or little shading parts so walk me
through your hair routine it's an old
ancient technique of water and a comb I
feel like I need to find a style that
works with it because it's thinning I
think that you can definitely rock
different looks within seconds your
whole entire being kind of just change
it shifted I looked good when people
look at you you're looking straight on
to them so anything that's shorter
tighter here will focus on their jawline
will focus on their eyes so that it
eliminates the focus of any hair loss
we're gonna try everything possible
besides surgery I've had a couple
friends that have done a hair
restoration yeah there's only a handful
of people that actually know that I've
gotten the surgery wait so today so yeah
I'm not embarrassed of it I was able to
find something that really fit my budget
and did what I want so they took the
hair follicles from the back of my head
and placed them at the front and after
that eight nine months you start getting
your hair growing back I fixed what the
issue was and now I'm preventing some
guys don't care but if they care
you should ideally have a stylist that
you trust I think it's important for
guys to not only you know have an open
conversation with each other and be
honest about you like hey you know I'm
noticing something maybe you should
check it out or go see a stylist because
they really know what they're doing as
we're sort of talking about it embracing
it we can share the tips that we're
sharing right now I which I would never
have ever found without just having a
conversation yeah so this is positive
hair positive person yeah love it I
looked at it as the haircut I wish I
always had you look ten years younger
Wow hey
what do you think thank you so much
there's no shame in going bald than if
you are like that's fine yeah but I
think it's also important to know that
there are things you can do about it and
that if it's something that makes you
feel better take action